to spot a gravitational wave LIGO  physicists will try to detect a  stretching of space itself they will use  this enormous interferometer in  Livingston Louisiana and its twin in  Hanford Washington each facility has  arms for kilometres long laser light  bounces between massive mirrors at the  ends of each arm to look for the  stretching of space physicists compared  the lengths of the arms using a  technique called interferometry if a  gravitational wave stretches the arms by  different amounts light will be diverted  to a photo detector the arms are as long  as an airport runway but researchers  will have to compare their lengths to  within a billion of the width of an atom  and to do that they will have to damp  out all sorts of bigger vibrations  including the sound of distant surf a  rumble from trains on nearby tracks and  the shaking caused by small earthquakes  you